EU ministers meeting in the General
Affairs Council looked at the draft
agenda of the next European Council in
October and agreed that they are getting
closer to consensus on a final decision
about a new climate and energy policy
framework we have globally detected a
desire and a determination by all
participating member states in this
discussion to to come to an agreement at
the European Council on the new energy
climate framework but at the same time
we've also noted that there are still
many issues that need to be further
explored in order to find suitable and
acceptable compromises at the next
summit EU leaders are also expected to
discuss the economic situation in Europe
as well as international developments on
the basis of a report prepared by the
Italian presidency ministers also looked
at how to accelerate the implementation
of measures aimed at fostering growth
jobs and competitiveness in Europe
finally ministers adopted conclusions on
the EU strategy for the adriatic and a
union region this strategy aims at
strengthening cooperation between the
eight participating countries to the
benefit of 70 million citizens in the
light of the positive experience held in
the Baltic and in the linear region we
are confident than that this strategy
which will have to be endorsed by the
European Council in October we we
provide a very effective tool notably at
regional level for the better
implementation and promotion of you
common common strategy the idea is to
work together to tackle challenges which
are common to all countries in the
region so just protecting the marine
environment completing the transport and
energy networks and promoting
sustainable tourism